[Musique]
le beurre que nous recevons ces crèmes
dans sa bulle
le stockons ces crèmes durant toute la
journée
tout simplement
pour préparer le traitement bien qu'on
se croire premier traitement
ce premier traitement est tout
simplement la pasteurisation nous allons
par ce traitement de pasteurisation
détruire les germes microbiens enfermé
dans cette matière première pour pouvoir
ensuite cultivé donc au projet remet
dans une autre opération
cette opération de pasteurisation sont
faits dans un appareil le pasteurisateur
de quelle façon
alors de la façon suivante la crème
arrivent en continu sur cet appareil
elle circule dans un jeu de plaques ce
lien du sang en présence d'un
pasteurisateur à plaques d'un côté d'une
plaque
vous avez un courant de crème et de
l'autre côté vous avez la source de
chaleur est ici dans le cas précis de la
vapeur et justement quelle température
c'était la passion la pasteurisation se
fait en température différente suivant
les saisons de 90 à 95 degrés
centigrades
ils font mine alors c'est là le gros
problème c'est que c'est une classe
théorisation très rapide c'est à dire le
tant que contact de la crème à 90 ou 95
degrés centigrades est de l'ordre de 30
secondes a rappelé effectivement
cette crème sont donc c'est pas la
travailler on doit continuer à
travailler à chaud les parties se
reproduit exactement
donc elle refait chemin inverse sur
l'appareil leur plan général de
pasteurisateur elle va passer dans ces
différents éléments et elle va être
refroidis 10 12 degrés alors par de
l'eau glacée simplement lui d'avoir d'un
côté de la plaque l'acclamer la vapeur
et le phénomène masterisation en
phénomène de refroidissement d'un côté
de la plaque nous avons la crème l'autre
côté nous avons l'eau glacée et il y a
dans cet appareil à peu par a également
six appareils qui servent eux oui alors
une opération qui se passe entre le
moment de la pasteurisation et du
refroidissement
c'est ce qu'on appelle le dégazage qui a
pour but d'enlever les odeurs de cette
crème qui quelquefois préface est forte
ça c'est un peu dur différents systèmes
d'alimentation et les animaux voilà pour
ce premier traitement à présent la crème
demi de tout germe va être envoyée par
l'intermédiaire d'un réseau de tuyaux
qui la met à l'abri de toute
contamination va donc être envoyés vers
les plus où il sera ré en semences
alors cette maturation se passe donc à
basse température pour prenons seulement
la crème refroidie ces températures
varient suivant les saisons
on parlait de l'ordre de 10,2 degrés
centigrades et aussitôt après cette
grosse 3,10 mans de la crème punir au
but nous rajoutons de 2 à 3% de ferment
sur sur cette crème cette maturation
d'une opération assez longue de 15 à 18
heures
la crème maturée c'est ainsi qu'on
l'appelle va maintenant se transformer
véritablement en beurre pour cela elle
est battue dans cet appareil c'est le
barattage
[Musique]
à la suite de ce marathon le petit lait
s'échappent des crumbles il est
recueilli écrémé et sert à
l'alimentation des jeunes allemands le
beurre sort en rouleaux de la machine
pour être emballée sous différents
formats
c'est ce que l'on appelle aussi le
conditionnement il est stocké dans une
chambre froide dont la température se
situe entre -15 et -20 degrés pour une
conservation de 6 mois
cette production est venu 100 kg par an
est très standardisé et mécanisée ce qui
explique le peu de personnel que vous
avez vu en tout huit personnes quant à
la destination de la marchandise france
andorre belgique ce sont les principaux
marchés
nous
[Musique]